one day after the plunge shares in
Shanghai dropped again by as much as
five percent on Tuesday ending the day
one point seven percent lower the
roller-coaster ride has shaken
confidence in the market millions of
small investors dominate the stock
market in China they were encouraged by
the government to buy shares often with
borrowed money now that the boom has
turned into a bust many are angry the
market is dead the government should
have told the public they were planning
to save the market if there's trouble
you should tell the public but I didn't
see any official news switching mover oh
good I'm not optimistic I can't
liquidate my assets and most of my
capital is tied up but I'm in a good
state of mind and I'm not gonna kill
myself but when Chinese consumers lose
their money on the stock market they
have nothing left to spend and that puts
a damper on domestic consumption which
has repercussions far beyond China no
more money for German cars for example
that would be bad news for German
carmakers whose record global sales are
heavily dependent on the Chinese market